malade tout jcj mittal à paris france a
aussi brillé manila fait plein de sens
afin d augmenter
attention greenspan a cherché mon époux
thierry caution si moyen terme
la tension est montée à l'augmenter
les prix mais sans nous envoyer un poids
pour les soignants
pour la qualité et travailler
et au budget
mais ce travail va nous manger mais mon
choix est louable
sinon c'est ça
à fumer c'est mal à sélestat 0 anti
message montcabrier base autres convives
19 c'est pas la fête sa catch me couche
tous partout donc tout me consoler nous
toutes concernées martinique guadeloupe
guyane ce matin haïti le monde entier
donc si ce pari ne sont pas chez pièce
raison inutile que sortie pour metella
vie est en danger
et puis mettez personnel soignant en
danger parce que ça va coûter 15 août
[Musique]